promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans ProMix cité l'émission
qui vous parle de la place des femmes
dans le monde du travail aujourd'hui
focus sur le moral des femmes qui n'est
pas toujours auot fixe c'est ce qui
ressort du dernier baromètre Opin ou
pour elle active 86 % pensent ainsi que
la vie est difficile en tant que femme
et 80 % trouvent que les injonctions
sont encore trop fortes dit autrement on
attend trop d'elles qu'elles aient tout
le temps le moral ce qui n'est pas une
évidence 28 % donne ainsi une note
inférieure à 6/10 quand on leur demande
comment est leur état intérieur des
femmes donc pas toujours bien dans leur
peau d'autant que 42 % considèrent
qu'elles ont un niveau de stress élevé
58 % s'inquièent pour leur santé
physique et 39 % pour leur santé mentale
mais malgré ce tableau sombre 63 %
indique qu'elles vont bien le travail
est d'ailleurs source d'épanouissement
pour 60 % d'entre elles en revanche un
bon tiers ne se sent pas légitime à son
poste et un autre tiers confie que sa
vie aurait été plus simple si elle avait
été un homme voilà ProMix cité c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite sur public
sénna promixité vous a été présenté par
ngj acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle